at that ncaa swimming championship the
other day the one where that hulking
dude beat all the little girls and
everyone had to applaud for this
that that was not
the end of the transgender activism
there
it was not just one confused kid showed
up and swam this has become a cause
celeb for all of the transgender
activists both the people who are
sexually confused and their supporters
so there was a woman who showed up kelly
jay keane posey parker who is a really
terrific
activist anti-trans you know pro-woman
activist and she showed up and she asked
a giant hulking man in a dress not the
swimmer on the team just an older man
who was there asked him
not to go into the women's bathroom not
to go into the women's locker room and
this man treated
kelly with absolute contempt
on the basis of the comfort and dignity
of girls and women i'm asking you and
telling you please do not lose women's
faces it makes them feel uncomfortable
my girls and the other women i am with
are very comfortable with me
well fortunately i'm not your daughter
and my daughter is also not your
daughter that's right and she would
still
she would feel
very uncomfortable
right now you interrupted me excuse me
i'm not here for a debate back to you
right i would like to i would ask you to
please call off your dog
i'm asking you of a mother do not use
female faces
you are absolutely you're not a mother
you'll never and this man is there just
treating her excuse me hey call off your
dogs
hey call off your dogs treating her so
contemptuously he's bigger than her he's
just visibly a man when you hear these
stories you think oh quit picking on the
sexually confused people oh you know
come on you mean old feminist woman stop
but then you look at the reality and
it's a big hulking dude putting a woman
in her place and saying no i don't care
if you want to use the bathroom on your
own i don't care i'm going to use that
bathroom now i don't care if your
daughter wants to be able to change
without my prying eyes my sexually
disturbed eyes looking at her
and me getting naked too with all of my
male body parts visible
i'm gonna do it and you call off your
dogs and you shut your mouth and you let
me do it that's the reality of this
situation okay
the the chasm between the narrative and
the reality is pretty big
the narrative
trans trans women are women look at that
guy if you're listening to this clip you
can at least hear it in his voice does
he sound like a woman to you does he
look like a woman to you no he's a big
dude he's a big dude who lived for 50
years as a man who fathered three
children and who now claims that he is a
mother
but he's not a mother he's a big hulking
dude and he's saying i'm going to go in
and i'm going to get naked
if i want to go to a locker room i'm
going to get naked in front of your
daughter and you have to deal with that
if you want to have a bathroom you go to
the bathroom by yourself too bad i'm
going to go into that bathroom too and
shut up there's nothing you that's the
reality that's the sick reality of it
did you like that clip i hope you did
i'm glad you did ring the bell subscribe
get the notifications go to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show if
you would be so kind and you can head on
over right now to dailywire.com go check
out fouchy
unmasked this is my three-part
docu-series on fauci really never seen
before unprecedented stuff in this
series it's doing really really well so
we appreciate everyone who's watched it
go check that out today dailywire.com
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]